mi nombre es matisse tengo cinco años tengo
mylène los objetos que serán rojos
mi mama es hermosa le sacamos las lineas rectas
quien se tira un pedo con la boca soy yo
matisse soy autista
los pies en el agua de las aplicaciones de
realidades de quienes ofrecen un breve
incursión en las percepciones y
Francés esperando a una persona mayor
todo lo que creíamos en 5 años en este caso
que él mismo concuerda con su vida cotidiana
en casa con los que tienen
percepción diferente por lo que comentamos
gracias a sow experimentado un poco de la
calle
[Música]
cuando escribes tanto
estas sumas sin integrarlas por otro lado
así de buena es la sonrisa de verdad
cuento sobre el jem ojos rojos que
es rojo que es rojo que nosotros
expresando en su salario y
sabores de algo si su sitio
en nuestra memoria que van como nosotros
reto que no sea para nosotros el
la realidad virtual era como un
llegaron noticias para clips
contenidos creados desde un enfoque documental
es muy diferente a una persona
mientras que aquí estamos hablando de un trastorno del
espectro autista el espectro significa
realmente decir muchas maneras dcl
y yahoo manera de ser una persona
agrega que hace 30 años ser un ser
humanos todos somos muy buena tierra en
a partir de lo mismo para
pescofis les cuento ya esta listo creando
un personaje ficticio a partir de datos
de todo lo que se hace en materia de culo
bueno, eso nos permitió
afirmar matiza cuando estás
No digas que lo más que es necesario apunta este
el campo no se reconoce como libre
así no entendí lo que tu
espera que me divierta cuando digo
está cerca eso significa que te detienes
jugando todo en el vt me imputa
voto rentable ok sin estos
matisse simple para todas las etapas
de la investigación al diseño
humanista dije agregado
quien me pidio que viniera a la mesa mudo
desde matisse aunque no hable
mucho soy una división soy
muy feliz y sobrevive bajo lo que
Amo y observo como si yo
cayó en
No me gustan los sonidos fuerza de los miedos
realmente poco ético y se repite mucho
pero miralos no se si tienes menos
Capa no me surge
no entiendo en la cara mamá entonces
su cuerpo para que no parezca una marioneta
de madera cuando me habla jean tant
mejor cuando miro hacia otro lado
Me encanta cuando mamá se negó y él a mí.
decir instrucciones para está claro soy
matisse no estoy triste
[Música]